je pense qu'il a soit au roi valet ou
vallée disent quelque chose comme ça on
a avalé on est un valet est-ce que vous
pouvez retourner vos cartes
est ce qu'on peut voir si vous avez une
paire ou pas dans son
[Musique]
saluons revient sur un format analyse
aujourd'hui on va analyser quelque chose
que vous m'avez demandé depuis longtemps
à savoir des parties de poker
je ne sais pas si vous êtes au courant
mais il n'y a pas si longtemps que ça
j'avais fait une émission pour patrick
sabatier où je retrouvais des joueurs de
poker avec cyril hanouna poissy reda
minnawi iab et cyril hanouna
il joue apparemment depuis 15 ans avec
le même groupe de personnes et il a
tendance à perdre et ils m'ont invité
pour analyser le jeu de ces personnes ce
que je vous propose c'est qu'on récupère
la vidéo et qu'on réanalyse un petit peu
tout ce qui s'est passé n'est en moi ma
vidéo peut être craqué parce que ces
huit n'aime pas qu'on utilise leur image
même si c'est toi qu'a fait le contenu
du coup on a fait des demandes des gens
n'a récupéré ce qu'on pouvait donc c'est
la qualité que ça a mais on y voit assez
on a fait le test ça roule
et puis on va faire un peu d une bizarre
et les ai fait un peu bizarre parfois
pour essayer de tromper le comte taille
dit voilà et j'ai tout à vous et vous
pouvez me mettre en prison youtube
alors on va surtout se concentrer sur
ces personnes là qui sont donc les amis
de cyril hanouna et apparemment ils font
des partis je crois depuis 20 ans
réalité et depuis dix ans ils marquent
tous les résultats ils tiennent des
stats et donc c'est à dida qui perd le
plus souvent et apparemment il n'aime
pas trop ça perdre donc l'idée c'était
vraiment que j'analyse leur réaction
pour essayer de donner des tips à
l'inades comment peut il fonctionner et
puis en même temps moi j'ai essayé de
faire un petit peu plus regardons ça
alors en fait ça fait à peu près 25 ans
qu'on joue ensemble on s'est dit un jour
qu'on allait pas répertorié tout ça et
puis c'est garder un petit historique un
peu ça fait 25 ans que ça dure mais moi
je souhaite dernier de rester telle
demande est marrant et on en fait on
fait des parties mais quand il sent qui
perd la règle et le change
pour info je suis relativement stressé
parce que ces solutions c'est vraiment
vite et à larache j'ai su ce que j'avais
à faire à la dernière seconde en fait en
arrivant pas du tout ce qui était prévu
au départ
on me voit un peu paumé parce que je ne
sais pas trop ce que je vais faire
il va nous apprendre et m'apprendra mois
à lire j'apprends
ce que je dois faire on le voit je fais
ça oui d'accord ok tu me vois passer la
lèvre c'est vraiment le c'est quoi votre
prénom
olivier olivier stéphane stéphane ça va
être plus dur avec vous mais beaucoup de
sang froid
jérôme et jérôme je roule je me suis dis
donc celui qui est tout autre bout de la
table soit c'est un flambeur soit c'est
un très très bon joueur c'était
forcément l'un des deux par rapport à ce
qu'ils dégagent tous les clichés qu'on
peut avoir sur lui je m'en imprègne à ce
moment là et je me dis du coup je vais
pas faire de commentaire sur qui il est
parce que sinon il va se méfier trop
vite de moi donc là pour que ça aille
plus vite on coupe un peu quand cyril à
mélanger et distribué etc
ils viennent tous d'être servis de deux
cartes et il va ya voir le flop après
sur la table il joue apparemment hold'em
et donc ils commencent à regarder leurs
cartes
et pendant que le regard de leur carte
moi je ne fais que les regarder mais il
ya quand même quelque chose de très
difficile à faire ça parce que comme je
suis invité est présenté par sabatier
pour dire que je fais les analyser il
faut encore plus attention à comment ils
vont être parce qu'ils savent que
quelqu'un les observe plus intensément
que des bikinis alors que je pense que
c'était un bon de le faire ok alors
c'est intéressant ce qui va me faire de
revérifier son jeu parce qu'en général
quand on est bien servi on ne le regarde
aussi l'amnésique aux siens ça c'est
intéressant pour moi ce qu'il vient de
dire cyril hanouna parce que moi il
regarde ses cartes plusieurs fois et
quand tu as un jeu qui est servi
directement
tu as moins tendance à les regarder
parce que tu sais ce que tu as et tu vas
juste contrôler tu vois c'est plus quand
tu as quelque chose de dépareiller de
semis intéressant ou de pas intéressant
que tu vérifies une ou deux fois ce que
tu as mais il me manque la baseline on a
déjà parlé dans les vidéos c'est à dire
tout le contexte qui est la personne
habituellement et la syrie ne me donne
le code en disant tuner lui il est
amnésique à chaque fois et je me dis ok
c'est intéressant ça veut dire que ce
point là ce tales la cette attention
d'une laque que je peux porter sur lui
elle n'est pas viable à 100%
est ce que vous avez je suis pas
mécontent alors vous avez vu par rapport
à tout à l'heure il ya quelque chose de
terrible c'est qu'il bouge beaucoup plus
que tout à l'heure en début de partie
ressources écart qui les regardent ils
restent neutres si on mettait un triplé
on vous verrez la commencer à bouger à
dandiner vous avez fait beaucoup d'avant
en arrière et nous on peut le mettre le
replay si vous regardez bien quand il
regarde une deuxième fois ses cartes il
dit je suis pas mécontent mais regardez
comment lui il se dandine à ce moment là
comment il est mal à l'aise je suis pas
mécontent alors vous avez vu tout ce
mouvement de se rasseoir d'essayer de
cacher ça il n'était pas comme ça au
tout début de la partie évidemment
donc c'était ma baseline le début de la
partie et là tu te dis ok donc c'est
vrai qu'il a un minimum de quelque chose
soit il a une petite paire de services
n'ont pas une très grosse soit il à des
buts quelque chose peut-être un début de
couleurs un des buts quinte
mais encore une fois y'a rien qui est
tombée sur le flop le flop c'est les
cartes qu'on va mettre et sur lequel si
vous connaissez pas le poker tout le
monde va composer son jeu en plus de ces
deux cartes
tout à l'heure il ya quelque chose de
terrible c'est qu'il bouge beaucoup plus
que tout à l'heure en début de partie
ressources écart qui les regardent ils
restent neutres si on mettait un triplé
on vous verrez la commencer à bouger à
dandiner vous avez fait beaucoup d'avant
en arrière je pense que vous avez perçu
quelque chose
j'ai regardé on vous l'avez vu vous le
connaissiez le petit plus aux tests
physiques je pense que vous avez perçu
quelque chose et lui qui me regardent en
faisant baisser c'est imperceptible vous
vous le voyez vous pouvez leur mettre un
petit peu en arrière mais il est en
train d'activer c'est ça et moi je le
note quand le nouveau kart et regardez
le flop
alors oui certains diront qu'elle n'a as
l'air de s'en bat les couilles de ce que
je raconte à ce moment précis je pense
que c'est le cas je pense qu'il ya une
paire hockey regarder de nouveau votre
jeu alesi s'il vous plaît moi je suis
sûr je sais ce que j'ai lu des phrases
il est plus confiant que tout à l'heure
la regarder encore la satisfaction on a
paniqué
on a vraiment le sourire si vous avez
juste vu là il est monté là redescendus
ça se joue au millimètre
mais les très contente de ce qu'il a je
pouvais pas voir la dilatation de la
pupille d'aussi loin malheureusement en
plus j'ai un peu midinette
mais on voit par contre les mouvements
des lèvres et puis il est comme ça ils
essayent de deux en fait de s'empêcher
de faire quoi que ce soit pression de
jouer on a pas de choses comme ça par
contre on a un contrôle contre les camps
mais ça là je suis en train de le dire
je viens de dire ce que je dis là on est
un petit peu en train de ne pas regarder
vos cartes fait me voir vos gardes serré
c'est une farce c'est excellent si vous
n'avez rien du tout crée vraiment que
d'allemagne vous mettez des jetons
virtuels juste j'ai envie que vous
ressentiez l'excitation est là je fais
semblant de vous regarder mais là ce que
vous savez pas c'est qu'il ya une coupe
et une reprise c'est pour ça qu'il me
demande si ils mettent des jetons en
fait moi je leur disais combien vous
pariez parce que j'ai besoin de
connaître les enjeux par rapport à
l'argent est presque ça peut générer
hélas au plateau à la télé ils ont fait
ce top ça on n'a pas le droit de parler
d'argent
et du coup c'est pour ça que j'ai dit
imaginez ce que vous feriez
virtuellement j'ai plus le droit de
prononcer ce mot là mais moi ça
m'empêchait de les mettre vraiment en
tension il n'y a pas eu de changement on
dort dîne plus - est-ce qu'on ait un ce
qui est à cause de la ce on a donc là il
ya un as qui vient de sortir et je
regarde leur réaction par rapport à ça
je veux juste te remettre un petit pas
en arrière on avait le flop qui était
servi
la turn vient de sortir c'est un as et
je regarde comment ils réagissent par
rapport à cette astuce que vous
ressentiez l'excitation est là je fais
semblant de vous regarder mais je
regarde lui a il ya pas eu de changement
on dort dîne plus ce qu'on dira ça l'a
calmé de l'as on est un peu inquiet oui
je pense que c'est vrai d'un point quand
il m'a dit on est un peu inquiet il a
fait oui de la tête en même temps ça
plairait un pléonasme physique
le corse en général ce que la voix dit
regardez vos cartes fait m'avoir vote
rictus et roger on a un projet on a un
projet les défenseurs will est un projet
de carte vous le voyez vraiment sur le
bas de son visage on voit toute la
sincérité il cache pas son jeu il dit
qu'il est dans la course
il est sur un projet à ce moment là je
pense qu'il est sur un projet de 15 ça
va se vérifier
vous pensez qu'il a quoi rien quelque
chose une paire dites moi comme ça un
petit peu au feeling rien rien et lui a
un truc
ok donc pour serena nous narre qui joue
depuis 25 ans avec ces gens là lui n'a
rien lui n'a rien et lui a quelque chose
c'est hyper intéressant parce que il n'a
pas du tout fait confiance en ce que je
disais à savoir tous les mouvements
corporels qu'indiquer que lui depuis le
départ il a quelque chose peut-être une
petite paire mais quelque chose
moi j'ai plus d'un 10 je suis près d'eux
lui on sait qu'il est sur le projet
quelque chose on sait aussi à ce moment
là qu'il ne l'a pas touché parce qu'il
n'a pas changé son état émotionnel d'une
virgule et lui on sait qu'il a une force
tranquille y protège quelque chose
quelque chose sûrement de fort hood e
semi fort vous allez voir j'ai pas tout
perdu chez lui parce que c'est un
excellent joueur
ok moi je vais vous dire je pense qu'il
a eu peur je pense qu'à chaque fois
qu'il aurait une paire dans toutes vos
futurs partis je pense que vous me
verrez se dandiner un petit peu comme ça
d'avoir en arrière et social et là on
voit que vous tournez vos cartes
est ce qu'on peut voir si vous avez une
terre ou pas dans son île
il a une paire de katia vingt quatre
heures le flop également il a pu la
toucher sa paire de cas donc il avait
touché depuis le flop quand il a senti
un élan pression je pense que là c'est
la dame ça vous parle
je pense qu'il a soit au roi valet ou
vallée disent quelque chose comme ça on
a un valet et un projet de 15 et un
plaisir et je pense qu'ils auraient un
mini battle avec notre ami parce que je
pense qu'il est pas servi au je pense
qu'il a sur une paire de 6 sur une paire
de 4 voilà c'est le seul point où j'ai
été faible en fait j'ai pas assez de
baseline sur lui je me dis soit il a une
paire de 6 soit une perte de 4 parce que
quand même des confiant mais il serait
parce les patients agressifs que ça tu
vois mais en même temps je vois que le
projet de calcul fait pas trop peur pour
l'instant il se sent m je pense qu'il a
eu la même lecture que moi en temps réel
et on va voir où est ce que j'ai fait
l'erreur
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire ce que
vous avez et on a peut-être les deux à
peut-être les deux en fait la presse
vers dessous une paire de 4 il avait 2
les personnes double paire
c'est un bon blocher alors que je vous
conseille quand vous jouez avec eux vous
regardez si dandine vous regardez son
petit rictus à droite et vous regardez
s'il essaye de contrôler sa main action
et voilà à la fin j'ai rempli ma mission
à savoir donner un type intel on appelle
ça un tel en fait la réaction de l'un
des joueurs sur chacun des joueurs qui
jouaient contre 6 rêve sur chacun de ses
amis c'est ça que vous devez faire si
vous jouez au poker juste comme ça pour
vous entraîner
vous pouvez jouer avec les mêmes
personnes lemieux de tentes se met en
dehors du jeu pour vraiment pas être
perturbés et vous essayez d'analyser sur
les petites choses c'est à dire que la
personne n'a rien et quand la personne à
quelque chose de petit jean rim perd
immédiatement vous devez analyser sa
baseline comment régler en temps normal
et qu'est-ce qui s'est modifié quand il
a perçu quelque chose ou au contraire
quand il n'a rien perçu
vous devez avoir les trois points le
rien le un peu où le projet et le très
fort et si vous avez ces trois choses là
avec la baseline habituel vous allez
pouvoir voir les différences et vous
améliorez en jeu alors évidemment ça ce
sont des conseils pour des gens qui ne
jouent pas beaucoup les grands joueurs
de poker eux déjà se protège c'est pas
pour rien en fait c'est pas pour faire
le show qui mettent des lunettes de
soleil
et puis une grosse kaboul et ses cancans
ils feront tapis c'est pour cacher tout
ce qui est possible de ne pas être
contrôlée ils ont conscience de ça de
l'or non verbale incontrôlable donc vous
pouvez le faire vous aussi également si
ça vous intéresse dit que le voit dans
les commentaires lake et la vidéo si ça
vous plaît et je vous ferai une vidéo
plus complètes sur le poker on pourrait
inviter des joueurs et que les détails
en temps réel et qu'on aille un peu plus
loin dans la lecture de sa donc vous le
demandez vous laïque et samassa motivera
le truc et vous me dites exactement ce
que vous aimeriez voir sur le poker dans
les com et puis voilà j'espère que ça
vous a plu
ici vous pouvez vous abonner à la chaîne
ici vous avez la vidéo de la semaine
dernière ici la prochaine vidéo la la la
la chaîne secondaire messi voilà c'est
tout à très bientôt
ciao